le début de mes recherches
on remonte à l'époque où j'étais
professeur d'histoire et géographie lors
de mes sorties pédagogiques ont bu cette
ville lgt chaque fois frappé par la
réticence de certains élèves à entrer
dans la chapelle pointue et à
s'approcher de la dalle funéraire de
madame desbassyns il faut dire que ce
personnage décédé en 1846 doit sa
célébrité à une mémoire orale et un
imaginaire collectif qui en ont fait une
véritable diablesse ces dernières années
j'ai pu consulter des documents
d'archivés qui montre que cette image de
madame desbassyns ne correspond pas
exactement à la réalité du personnage et
qu'elle relève en grande partie du mythe
et de la légende le mythe donne une
représentation déformée de la réalité
comme ce portrait de la femme
autoritaire méchante et cruel avec ses
esclaves mais il reste crédible car la
discipline était vraiment dur sur le
domaine de madame desbassyns et
aujourd'hui encore son nom est évoqué
pour qualifier un employeur soupçonnés
d' autoritarisme envers ses salariés
avec la légende
en revanche on entre dans le monde de
l'irrationnel des croyances des
superstitions un monde dans lequel
madame desbassyns est une créature
diabolique qui n'en finit pas
d'expliquer ces crimes dans les feux de
l'enfer du volcan et dont on dit que son
âme revient parfois hanter les vivants
le mythe négatif de madame desbassyns
apparaît plus d'un demi siècle après sa
mort mais il plonge ses racines à
l'époque où elle même et sa famille
défend des dépositions monarchistes et
cléricale dans une france de plus en
plus gagné par les idées républicaines
et laïques
dès le 19e siècle cette famille a ainsi
cristallisé autour d'elle les rancoeurs
suscitée par sa position sociale élevée
par son immense fortune par son
influence politique et religieuse la
légende de la
nature diabolique se développe surtout
lorsque les réunionnais apprennent
l'histoire et les horreurs de
l'esclavagé dont madame desbassyns
devient en quelque sorte le symbole
elle n'était pourtant pas la seule mais
la plus grande propriétaires d'esclaves
de lille mais une femme chef
d'entreprise au 19e siècle
je n'étais pas courant pour l'époque et
cela pourrait expliquer bien des choses
voilà donc les principaux thèmes que
j'ai développé dans mon livre